12h15 la sonde météo comme deux fois par
jour s'apprête à partir un lâché
pratiqué depuis maintenant 120 ans
1896 le plateau de Trapp proche de la
gare devient un laboratoire météorologie
Léon tesserin de bord chef de la
météorologie générale du BCM le Bureau
central de la météorologie en est le
fondateur en 1892 Léon T5 de bord
démissionne de ses fonctions officielles
et et à partir de là il va décider de
consacrer sa vie et et sa fortune voilà
à ses recherches en météorologie
dynamique en
1895 il y a le comité météorologique
international qui décide de lancer une
année internationale d'observation des
nuages et c'est Léon T5 de bord qui se
charge lui de de créer à ses frais
toujours une station française
pour les mesures d'observation de ces
nuages l'étude du temps se fait à
l'époque au sol mais Léon tesserin de
bord comprend que c'est d'un point de
vue vertical qu'il faut analyser il
réalise des lâchés de ser volant tractés
par un treuil électrique puis des
ballons avec son laboratoire leséon
tessrin de bord crée de nouveaux
systèmes de mesure tessrin de bord a
construit les premiers météorographes
c'est comme ça ça s'appelle c'est
instruments qui mesurent à la fois la
pression la température et l'humidité un
petit pareil qui était comme ça qui
pisait à peu près 500 g qu'on mettait
dans un petit panier et qui était
emporté par un ballon qui était gonflé
avec de l'hydrogène il y a un
lâché très vite le 8 janvier
1899 qui atteint bon l'altitude de 12 km
mais c'est surtout ce ce
premier ballonond qui lui permet de
mettre en évidence donc la le phénomène
de quasi isothermie de de couche d'air
situé audessus d'une certaine altitude
et c'est ce que c'est la découverte de
ce que Léon Tess ring lui-même appellera
plus tard la
stratosphère décédé en 1913 Léon
tesserin de bord laisse un héritage
matériel mais aussi de référence l'Atlas
international des nuages en 1896 et les
bases de la météorologie dynamique
rédigé tous deux avec Hugo î de Brand de
Branson météorologue suédois le
laboratoire est alors légué à un service
d'état